- Everybody has to wake up every day
and make a decision.
- In every situation.
- You can either choose to look at it
negatively or you can choose
to try to find the good.
- And say fuck it, I
should be able to be happy.
- It's a really interesting question.
I felt like life handed me an
extremely unfair set of cards.
- My gender at birth, was female
but I knew, for sure, that I was a man.
- I was the boy with no legs.
- I was unfulfilled.
- I struggled with PTSD.
- And I was told I have cancer.
- [Narrator] I felt like
my best was a failure.
- [Narrator] I was telling
myself that I wasn't enough.
- [Narrator] I locked myself away.
- [Narrator] I felt voiceless.
- [Narrator] Trapped.
- [Narrator] Extremely angry.
- I let the opinions of other people
literally dictate how I felt.
- And I asked myself why?
- I just knew, in that moment,
something has to change.
- And everything just hit me, it's like...
- Fuck it, I should be able to be happy.
- And I started looking into myself.
- And in that one specific moment,
I was able to find my
confidence in myself.
- Taking control of my life was a rebirth.
- Shedding all that baggage
was complete freedom.
- I was putting trust in me.
- And how I was gonna fulfill my life.
- That was my time where
I kind of realized that,
you know what, I got somethin' to prove.
- And I felt really empowered.
- Invincible.
- Alive.
- All of the sudden, I
wasn't the victim anymore.
I would be the victor.
- [Narrator] Now, I am an online
fitness coach, cancer free.
- [Narrator] I use cooking as a therapy.
- [Narrator] I am a transgender activist.
- [Narrator] I've won two gold, two silver
and a bronze medal at
the Paralympic Games.
- [Narrator] I'm doing
something that I love
for a living.
- Life is not easy.
- Why feed something
that's already so negative
in my life, with more negativity?
- You had control over that.
- There are no excuses, ever.
- There's no no in the equation.
There's no can'ts in the
equation, there's always a way.
- It's a responsibility to yourself.
- Your happiness is a choice away.
- Use it as an opportunity
to write the next chapter.
(upbeat music)